the opening scene features North Korea
launching an invasion on South Korea 5
years after the end of World War II we
are introduced to a young girl named
Soul joyfully chasing the butterflies in
her garden during this her parents
surprise her with a homemade bicycle
which makes the little girl very happy
her father helps her in writing it
portraying a beautiful moment between
the two however their happiness is
shortlived as the village experiences a
sudden deafening explosion killing
several people it turns out to be the
North Korean soldiers who are on the
verge of capturing the land reacting
quickly Soul's father asks his family to
stay somewhere safe while he joins the
other villagers to convince the soldiers
to stop attacking them Soul's mother
hides the little girl under a culvert
bridge and consoles her to stay there
before leaving to find her father
tragically all the villagers get killed
leaving Soul alone the then cuts to
iskenderun Turkey where a young man
named Ali is impatiently waiting for his
friend Suliman to head to work along the
way Ali grabs a painting of Marilyn
Monroe fueled by his immense uh
admiration for her meanwhile a girl
named gatsi calls out for her friend
nuran telling her to get ready because
the boys will be arriving in the alley
soon soon after the boys ride past the
alley and they exchange a romantic gaze
with each other following this the two
girls huddle in the middle of the alley
gatsa techi then expresses her concern
as she recalls her father mentioning
that the boys might be called up for
deployment to South Korea for war
however nuran brushes off the topic
believing that they are just young
college students who aren't yet prepared
for military service afterwards the boys
ride their bicycles to the 39th military
infantry division command there Suliman
meets with the major iskenderun who
informs him that they are going to
dispatch a group of young men to South
Korea as reinforcement along with other
military troops the major considers
Suliman as one of the proficient
soldiers needed and tells him to get
ready for the departure suan respects
the Major's decision and agrees to go to
war later on he informs his friends
about the deployment with price he also
asks one of them to relay this message
to nuran that same night sulaman goes to
meet Nan who is clearly upset by the
news of his departure she reveals that
she's an orphan with no one else to
depend on suan assures her that he'll
return as soon as the mission ends she
then tearfully tells him not to forget
her as he's the only one whom she can
rely on before departing they share an
emotional hug and bid farewell with a
kiss the following day while sailing
away in the ship Suliman writes letters
to his family friends and his beloved
nuran to his family and love he shares
only brighter aspects of his journey
while he informs his friends about being
equipped with weapons later Lieutenant
Mesut asks sulaman to fetch some diesel
because he's part of the motorized unit
in response sulaman suggests he siphons
some from a Jeep in storage during their
conversation Lieutenant Mesut reveals
that he's bothered by ants in his cabin
and as a solution Suliman advises him to
feed them instead of killing them here
hearing this Lieutenant meit Harbor's
doubt regarding siman's Readiness for
war because he can't even kill an ant
well meit can't even figure out how to
which is worse after a long journey the
troops finally arrive in South Korea
where they are warmly welcomed by the
citizens before long the commander
orders them to pack up as they will be
immediately heading to Dau City to meet
the South Korean soldiers upon their
arrival major fuat informs the troops
that despite being captured by the North
Korean Soldiers the peace keeping forces
drove back the enemy to its borders and
freed South Korea from The Invasion now
their final destination is kunu RI and
the team proceeds towards it upon
reaching there Ali and Lieutenant me
engage in a heated debate about their
perspectives regarding the war Suliman
tries to intervene but just then the
North Koreans suddenly launch their
attack this prompts the three of them to
run toward Commander Cal's cabin inside
the commander is trying to establish
emergency contact with the ninth core
but communic ation signals are now
disrupted by the explosion sensing the
emergency of calling a backup the
commander decides to head towards ninth
core Command Center recognizing
suliman's driving skills and Lieutenant
meit's proficiency As an interpreter the
commander assembles a team in order to
set out to their destination on a Jeep
as the team drives through a village
they come under sudden enemy attack
fortunately they managed to jump off the
vehicle moments before it explodes Ali
promptly gets up and uses his pistol to
fend off the attackers bravely with
their vehicle gone the team decides to
continue the rest of their Journey on
foot while walking they hear a noise
prompting the soldiers to pull out their
guns and stay alert shortly after
sulaman investigates the sound and
eventually discovers the innocent Soul
sitting beside her deceased mother
feeling bad for her siman offers his
hand suggesting the little girl come
with him although hesitant at first Soul
soon agrees and siman takes her back to
his team the entire group feels sad for
the girl so they decide to take her
along upon her arriving at the ninth
core the commander heads inside to
report about the attack on their base
while the others swayed outside during
this Ali suggests that they provide the
girl with a new name since they can't
talk with her due to the language
barrier as a result they name her Aya
because of her moonlike face then they
realize that changing her name didn't
help with the language barrier
afterwards the American Commander
conducts a meeting in which he states
that the war has just begun moreover he
claims that it has taken on a
multinational aspect with China
supporting North Korea and turkey
supporting South Korea along with this
information the American Commander
offers the team with some additional
resources including another vehicle and
Personnel Captain cage and Lieutenant
Lee their role is to assist the team and
guide them through a new undisclosed
route following this the team continues
on their Journey with Aya alongside them
Suliman seems to be taking good care of
her despite the language barrier a while
later the team stops in the middle of
the road they discuss an optimal route
to reach kunu RI in a shorter period of
time when they're all set to go Captain
Cage's Jeep doesn't start so they summon
suluman to fix it however when he tries
to step out of the vehicle Aya grabs his
arm giving him a sign not to let go of
her due to this he places her on the
vehicle's Bonnet letting her watch him
as he repairs after successfully getting
the job done they are about to leave but
just then a North Korean sniper shoots a
South Korean Soldier this triggers
intense gunfire between the two parties
killing several sold soers in the
process in a hurry suan grabs Aya and
shelters her under the Jeep facing a
barrage of enemy attacks he improvises a
bomb using a gas bottle and a tire
killing the incoming enemies thankfully
the sound of the explosion is heard by
the rest of their teams prompting them
to rush to the rescue in the meantime
suan gets into a fight with one of the
enemy soldiers during which he gets
stabbed in the shoulder he's nearly
killed but Lieutenant Lee manages to
shoot down the enemy in the nick of time
meanwhile the news of the outbreak of
War spreads far and wide causing worry
for suliman's family and his beloved
back home the next day Suliman regains
his Consciousness in a medical camp and
finds Aya holding his hand everyone at
the camp Praises his bravery
highlighting his courageous actions in
the previous enemy encounter they also
reveal that Aya remained by his side the
entire night a short while later suon
learns that the Koreans had attacked the
team because they wanted to take Aya
with them regardless she refuses to
leave Suliman even though it's clear now
that it's endangering everybody so
Lieutenant Lee decides to talk to the
headquarters in the subsequent meeting
Lee suggests that they temporarily house
the children in the headquarters until a
safer place is arranged for them
thankfully the senior officials accept
the suggestion even though it needlessly
endangers everybody the following day
the major informs suluman that the war
is getting intense making it difficult
for them to keep Aya with them upon
hearing this Suliman decides to leave
her with an officer named sadik the
latter assures him that they'll treat AA
as his child he even reveals a warm coat
that he made for her however Suliman
struggles to leave her behind as Aya
continues to follow him as a result of
this sadik takes charge and seats Aya in
the Jeep but when he is distracted she
sneaks back into Simon's Jeep after this
Suliman and the team drive towards the
awards ceremony where the soldiers are
going to receive medals for their
bravery once there AA surprisingly runs
towards Suliman when he is receiving
recognition from the South Korean
Captain because of this the team is
forced to bring Aya back to the base as
the days pass by Suliman spends much of
his time taking care of Aya while also
practicing with his troops eventually
everyone in the camp establishes an
attachment to the little girl one night
AA struggles with sleeping after hearing
the lightning outside so she goes to
sleep beside Suliman the next morning
she utters a word for the very first
time which surprises everyone in the
camp Bitcoin this prompts the team to
start teaching her the Turkish language
during their free time and also letting
her her watched Turkish movies at one
point Aya refers to Suliman as her
Father which touches him deeply now that
she knows suliman's name she hears some
team members discuss their Fates with
one of them suggesting that suon might
die this causes AA to break down into
tears and she rushes to sulaman to share
this in order to cheer her up he claims
that the soldiers were talking about
others that's right Gaslight the child
in the next scene suan Ali and Mees take
Aya to Tokyo for a children's holiday
she thoroughly enjoys her time with the
three of them they purchase dresses for
her relish delicious meals dance and
capture Precious Moments in photographs
after such an enjoyable day Suliman
suddenly gets emotional because of the
thoughts of having to abandon Aya once
he returns to Turkey the next day sadik
informs Suliman of the family who are
claiming to be Aya's relatives hearing
this Suliman hands her a piece of note
before heading to meet the family alone
upon reaching the provided address he
discovers that it's a trap set by the
North Koreans who immediately mediately
start beating him up meanwhile back in
the base alif freaks out when he
realizes that suon is missing
fortunately AA knows the address so she
guides Ali and sadik to the place the
men immediately beat up the bandits and
rescue Suliman from them after a while
the major announces a small concert
featuring Marilyn Monroe upon hearing
this Ali expresses his wish to attend it
as he's a huge fan of hers but sadly his
duties prevent him from going as a
result of this Suliman promises Ali that
he'll obtain maryn's autograph for him
can't touch myself to an autograph says
Ali accompanied by Aya and Lieutenant me
suan attends the concert and with the
help of Aya they successfully secure
Marilyn's autograph with a kiss mark on
it meanwhile back at the base Ali is
gazing at a picture of Marilyn Monroe
when he is fatally shot by a North
Korean sniper on the border at long last
lending logic to the title of the movie
Die Hard after learning of this tragic
news sulaman is overwhelmed with grief
and cannot hold his tears back he then
decides to leave behind a last gift for
Ali the autographed picture of Marilyn
Monroe one year later the major
announces that the current batch of
soldiers will be returning home making
way for new troops to join despite this
Suliman chooses to stay for another year
as a volunteer because he can't leave
Aya he writes a heartfelt letter to
nuran informing her of his decision and
then bids farewell to his friends later
on the commander summons Suliman into
his cabin and informs him that it's time
for them to return home because they'll
be handing over the command to new
Turkish officers furthermore they cannot
allow suluman to take Aya with him since
she's Korean left with no other option
Suliman takes Aya to her new home the
anara school with a heavy heart he
starts to walk away but she continues to
follow him in a desperate attempt to
bring her along Suliman comes up with an
idea to hide her in his suitcase and
take her with him on the ship
unfortunately his plan fails when muit
discovers that Aya is missing despite
his desperate please he is isn't allowed
to take Aya hence he is forced to leave
her behind before departing he makes a
heartfelt promise to return to her and
ensures that they'll be together from
then onwards following this Suliman
finally returns to Turkey only to
discover that nuran is already married
to someone else this news leaves him
devastated and with a broken heart he
goes to nimat he marries nimt before
returning back home the days pass by but
their marriage appears to lack happiness
because suliman's mind is always
occupied by Aya generously met makes
every effort to establish contact with
Aya but fails the scene then fast
forwards 47 years and we see everyone is
gathered outside their homes due to an
earthquake however the old Suliman goes
back into his house to retrieve an old
photograph of him with AA even after an
extended period of time he spends his
time watching Korean television news and
games in the hope of finding any
information about Aya he even dreams of
Aya visiting him in Turkey one day
Suliman and nimt received a call from a
Korean news reporter who wants to help
Suliman reunite with Aya they propose
making a documentary and assisting in
the search suon eagerly agrees and he is
filled with hope one more time following
this the news team begins conducting
diligent research to find Aya after
several years the news crew finally
succeeds in locating her they
immediately arrange a reunion with Aya
in South Korea after all those years of
staying apart Suliman and AA reunite in
Soul ending the movie with this
emotional scene
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching